[Música]
el narcotraficante más buscado de
colombia fue capturado en el
noroccidente del país
dairo antonio úsuga alias otoniel jefe
del clan del golfo podría enfrentar
ahora la extradición a eeuu
el presidente de bandung que indicó que
esta captura significa el fin de la
organización criminal
miles de emigrantes avanzan hacia el
norte de mexico en una nueva caravana
que partió desde la ciudad de tapachula
donde se encontraban instalados en su
mayoría de los viajeros provienen de
haití el salvador honduras y guatemala e
intentan llegar en una primera instancia
a la capital mexicana para luego
dirigirse hasta la frontera con eeuu
desde seúl el enviado especial de eeuu
para corea del norte le pidió al régimen
de pyongyang que frene las provocaciones
en referencia a las recientes pruebas
con misiles balísticos y señaló que
washington tiene la intención de
negociar para acabar con los
enfrentamientos en la península
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentín a torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en colombia en
un operativo conjunto entre la policía y
el ejército fue capturado dairo antonio
úsuga alias otoniel el narcotraficante
más buscado del país que dirige la
organización del clan del golfo es
pedido en extradición por eeuu que
ofrecía la suma de 5 millones de dólares
por su detención el término de
narcotraficante fue aprendido en el
municipio de necoclí cercano a la
frontera panameña y el presidente iván
duque señaló que su captura es la más
importante desde pablo escobar andrés
granadillo nos amplía
otoniel uno de los narcotraficantes más
buscados de colombia el presidente iván
duque mostró la captura del líder del
clan del golfo como un gran logro de su
gobierno este es el golpe más duro que
se le ha propiciado al narcotráfico en
este siglo en nuestro país
y este golpe es solamente comparable con
la caída de pablo escobar en los años 90
pero antonio úsuga fue imputado por la
justicia estadounidense en 2009 enfrenta
un proceso de extradición para que
comparezca ante la corte del distrito
sur de nueva york este país ofrecía una
recompensa de 5 millones de dólares por
su captura y suba quien comenzó su vida
ilegal en la guerrilla izquierdista de
lepe él lideraba hasta su detención un
grupo paramilitar conocido como
autodefensas gaitanistas de colombia el
grupo según el gobierno se financia
principalmente con el tráfico de drogas
la minería ilegal y la extorsión pero la
captura de otoniel no implica el fin de
la organización ni del narcotráfico
pero hay cuatro personas que han sido de
su confianza que han ascendido digamos a
partir de que han dado de baja a otro de
los cabecillas entonces tenemos cuatro
posibilidades de que ellos hagan una
organización y sigan en la estructura o
muy posiblemente se fragmente en el clan
del golfo es acusado de ser uno de los
principales responsables de la peor ola
de violencia que atraviesa el país desde
2016 cuando el gobierno colombiano firmó
la paz con la guerrilla de las farc
una nueva caravana con miles de
emigrantes centroamericanos partió desde
la ciudad mexicana de tapachula
fronteriza con guatemala hacia el norte
del país los ciudadanos que lograron
llegar hasta el municipio de álvaro
obregón a 14 kilómetros de su punto de
partida caminan rumbo a ciudad de méxico
para regularizar su situación de asilo y
para solicitar al gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador una autorización de
trabajo los migrantes provienen en su
mayoría de haití el salvador honduras y
guatemala
lo que pasa es que le han dado más las
informaciones
se engañan
ahora mismo pues ha dado resolución para
que visiten
nos vamos a invitar a superman a que
sean conscientes porque aquí todo es muy
caro
no podemos estar reprimidos
como estar preso cerca de 200 personas
muchas de ellas del mundo
cinematográfico llevaron a cabo una
vigilia en homenaje a jal ina hastings
la directora de fotografía que falleció
tras recibir accidentalmente un disparo
del actor alec baldwin durante la
grabación de una película los asistentes
encendieron velas guardaron momentos de
silencio leyeron poesía en honor a
hopkins al tiempo expresaron
preocupación por las condiciones de
seguridad en sus propios rodajes
aseguraron que es necesario que se
garanticen condiciones adecuadas de
trabajo
en otras noticias desde corea del sur el
enviado especial de eeuu para corea del
norte kim señaló que seguirá discutiendo
posibles opciones para que se retoma el
diálogo con pyongyang kim destacó que
washington no tiene ninguna intención
hostil con el régimen de kim jong-un y
añadió que espera lograr una propuesta
para poner fin a los enfrentamientos
entre las coreas previamente pidió a
pyongyang que cese las provocaciones en
referencia a las recientes pruebas de
misiles balísticos que calificó de
preocupantes y contraproducentes
nuestro objetivo sigue siendo la
desnuclearización completa de la
península de corea y estamos trabajando
en estrecha colaboración con nuestro
aliado la república de korea es por eso
que la reciente prueba de misiles
balísticos de pyonyang una de varias en
las últimas seis semanas es preocupante
y contraproducente para lograr avances
hacia una paz duradera en la península
este lanzamiento viola múltiples
resoluciones del consejo de seguridad de
la onu y representa una amenaza para los
vecinos de corea del norte y la
comunidad internacional
un temblor de magnitud 6 5 sacudió el
noreste de taiwán este domingo sin que
hasta el momento se reporten daños la
oficina meteorológica detalló que el
sismo se sintió en el norte el este y el
oeste del país y tuvo como epicentro el
condado de yilán el metro de taipei
retomó sus operaciones tras una breve
suspensión y no se registraron cortes en
el servicio de electricidad
la organización mundial de la salud
advirtió que la pandemia durará un año
más de lo necesario por la desigualdad
en el reparto de vacunas todo ello a
pesar de las promesas de los países
ricos de donar millones de dosis al
programa kóvacs de naciones unidas- que
sufre un severo retraso ya que en
algunas regiones entre ellas el
continente africano apenas ha podido
llegar a la población veamos el
siguiente informe
la pandemia durará un año más de lo
necesario por la desigualdad de las
vacunas la razón los países más pobres
no están recibiendo suficientes dosis
según el organismo mundial de la salud
esto significa que la pandemia podría
prolongarse fácilmente hasta el 2022
según los datos proyectados en la web
our world in that a poco menos del 8% de
la población de áfrica ha recibido una
dosis de la vacuna esto contrasta con
otras regiones del mundo en eeuu y
canadá el 67 por ciento de la población
cuenta con al menos una dosis en américa
latina' el 61 por ciento mientras que en
europa llega al 58 por ciento y en asia
al 57 para abordar el problema el año
pasado se estableció un programa de
distribución de vacunas a nivel mundial
en el que los países más ricos se
comprometieron a donar dosis y a
subsidiar los costos para las naciones
más pobres conocido como kóvacs su
objetivo inicial era proporcionar 2 mil
millones de vacunas en todo el mundo
este año una meta que no se cumplirá
ahora se espera que el programa cuente
con un total de 1.400 millones de dosis
para finales de 2021 el lunes la unión
europea aseguró que planea aumentar las
donaciones de vacunas los países más
vulnerables
opinión la unión europea ha exportado
más de mil millones de vacunas contra el
coi 19 al resto del mundo
goes
entregamos alrededor de 87 millones de
dosis a los países de ingresos bajos y
medianos a través de kóvacs así que
cumplimos nuestra promesa rooms sin
embargo un análisis de people's boxing
una alianza de organizaciones benéficas
muestra que sólo una de cada siete de
las dosis prometidas por las naciones
más ricas y las compañías farmacéuticas
está llegando a su destino en los países
más pobres
hablamos ahora de política francesa la
candidata del partido socialista y
alcaldesa de parís anne hidalgo celebró
el sábado mitin ante unos 1700 miembros
del partido para el aspirante
presidencial de origen español esta fue
una oportunidad de dar un impulso a su
campaña
arrancando su primer mitin ante sus fans
espera déjame saludar a mis amigos para
su primer acto proselitista como
candidata oficial del partido socialista
francés la emoción se sentía en el aire
plaza en nueve posibles internacionales
muy conocida en los círculos
internacionales y europeos es una mujer
y vamos a apoyarla pero no todos los
partidarios de la ciudad de lille están
convencidos de que pueda ganar tiene
trabajo por delante eso es seguro
las encuestas muestran que a hidalgo no
le está yendo bien ahora mismo la sitúan
en el noveno puesto para la primera
vuelta de las elecciones con sólo el 5%
de los votos su pálido comienzo es un
golpe para los socialistas en el mitin
de lille acudieron a prestarles su apoyo
líderes del mismo partido al que fue una
vez la principal fuerza política de
francia como la alcaldesa de lille es la
alcaldesa de parís oigo a la gente decir
a ellas la alcaldesa de parís y que eso
es algo de lo que hay que estar
orgulloso es la alcaldesa de parís brabo
han por todo lo que haces y de algo
asegura que los electores están cansados
de lo que llamo la condescendencia del
gobierno de manuel makoun ojos
en francia no hay un júpiter ni una
figura enviada por el cielo en francia
hay franceses que viven piensan y
merecen ser considerados
jiménez de la acción para los miles de
simpatizantes en la multitud que
vinieron de toda francia para el mitin
esto es solo el comienzo
para ganar impulso realmente lo creo por
eso estoy aquí hoy a menos de seis meses
de las elecciones presidenciales y de
algo tiene que escalar una empinada
cuesta pero ella y sus partidarios dicen
que están preparados para poner en
marcha su campaña
el futbolista francés retirado hace dos
años patrice evra reveló que fue
sexualmente abusado cuando iniciaba su
adolescencia el ex defensa del
manchester united hizo las declaraciones
a un medio británico como parte de una
entrevista antes de presentar su
autobiografía que saldrá al mercado esta
semana
sí
patricio graff una pieza fundamental en
la defensa de la selección francesa de
fútbol por más de 20 años pero recién
ahora ha surgido otro lado de su
historia un capítulo oscuro durante su
adolescencia que nadie ni siquiera a su
madre conocía focus shows personal hay
muchas cosas que me han pasado en la
vida y que nunca he comentado ni
siquiera a mis padres va a ser una
sorpresa muy grande para ellos y no una
bonita porque en un libro no solo hay
cosas buenas pack de ever sold como
niega por primera vez hebra reveló que
en su adolescencia fue víctima de abuso
sexual en una entrevista para el diario
inglés times que tuvo acceso exclusivo a
su libro evra dijo lo siguiente me daba
vergüenza admitir que había sido abusado
sexualmente pero no quiero que otros
niños sientan lo mismo el abuso sucedió
cuando tenía 13 años en ese entonces
vivía con un profesor tres noches por
semana pensaba que estaba dormido metía
sus manos debajo de las sábanas y
trataba de tocarme hacía lo posible para
quitarme los calzoncillos por lo que
brand convenció a su madre que le
permitiera vivir en otro lugar sin
contarle por qué quienes apoyan a las
víctimas o sexual dicen que su confesión
podría impulsar a otros a hacer lo mismo
si gente conocida da la cara a las
víctimas se sentirán menos solas les
parecerá más fácil encontrar el coraje
para contar su verdad pero para el
futbolista lo más difícil fue contarle
del abuso a su madre más de dos décadas
después
en otras noticias cientos de afganos
varados en el lado paquistaní de la
frontera se enfrentaron a las
autoridades pidiendo la reapertura del
paso de chamán el segundo más importante
a nivel comercial los ciudadanos
lanzaron piedras a los agentes
fronterizos que respondieron con gases
lacrimógenos para dispersarlos el paso
lleva tres semanas cerrados por las
autoridades paquistaníes que temen un
flujo masivo de afganos que tratan de
salir del país desde que el grupo
talibán tomó el poder en agosto
todas las personas atrapadas aquí están
en una gran miseria nosotros sólo
pedimos que no se ha dado una pequeña
oportunidad para que podamos volver a
casa estamos protestando porque todos
están cansados de estar atrapados aquí
el frío nos está destruyendo la verdad
uzbekistán celebra elecciones
presidenciales este domingo sin la
participación de candidatos opositores
el actual presidente jacques cat mir sí
y oye busca su reelección
las autoridades electorales declararon
los comicios como válidos luego de que a
mitad de jornada se registrará una
participación del 33 por ciento de los
21 dos millones de ciudadanos que están
habilitados para votar las elecciones se
han llevado a cabo sin reportes de
incidentes y según los observadores
transcurren de manera transparente
tras un año suspendida por la pandemia
este domingo volvió a hong con su
conocida maratón en la que participaron
unas 15 mil personas los estrictos
esquemas que mantiene la ciudad para
frenar el coi 19 hicieron que pocos
extranjeros pudieran correr la
competencia los locales jon kyl ok y
djukic increased y ganaron la maratón en
categoría masculina y femenina
respectivamente la carrera se vio
ensombrecida por denuncias de exclusión
a atletas opositores al gobierno
y finalizamos en egipto la iniciativa
artística arte jeep organizó una
exposición internacional de arte
contemporáneo con las famosas pirámides
de giza como telón de fondo la muestra
cuenta con obras de diez artistas dos de
ellos locales y estará abierta al
público hasta el 7 de noviembre
y vamos a dar un vistazo a lo que titula
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
antes de despedirnos capturan a alias
otoniel el jefe del clan del golfo y el
narcotraficante más buscado de colombia
en otras noticias turquía informa que
declarara a 10 embajadores incluidos de
francia persona 'non grata'
y así llegamos al final de este
informativo ustedes gracias por su
sintonía y los invitamos a repetir esta
y otras emisiones en nuestra web
france24 puntocom y a continuar con
nuestra programación aquí en france 24
[Música]